the movie the last black man in San
Francisco you're going to be talking
about this it earned top honors at the
Sundance Film Festival for its poetic
portrayal of a changing city and poetic
is word here the stories based on the
life of Jimmy fails who makes his acting
debut thank you very much follows his
journey to reclaim his childhood home in
a neighborhood his family can no longer
afford the movie addresses how many
black families were forced from their
homes in San Francisco because of
redevelopment in a lack of affordable
housing award-winning actor Danny Glover
portrays the blind grandfather that
fails his best friend and in this clip
Glover's character confronts them about
sneaking around as they try to take back
fields home home I never made you feel
like you were welcome here no I never
felt like that
cuz I don't care where you been you
don't have to tell me it's just you two
sis together Jimmy fails and Danny
Glover join us at the table
congratulations to you both as we've all
seen the movie I keep using the word
haunting to describe it Jimmy you have
said that this is a love letter to a
home what do you mean by that well you
know a home represents a lot of
different things for a lot of different
people my home is represented family
represented black ownership my
grandfather owned that property so
that's pretty much why the house means
so much to me was it difficult for you
to go back and see this story told on
the big screen knowing that so many
elements are true to your own life not
necessarily I mean everyone that helped
us make the movie there was a big
beautiful collaboration with a lot of
beautiful people that we met they always
rally behind me and helped me get
through that if I did it was a pitch to
you Danny Glover to get you involved
mr. award-winning actor I was so moved
by the story because I'm a native of San
Franciscan I live in the same
neighborhood that I've lived in since
I'm 11 years old my parents have an
opportunity because they were postal
workers like a number of other African
Americans had an opportunity to purchase
a home you know and and so their
children didn't have the same
opportunity because they didn't have the
jobs one and it's got the price of
housing increase dramatically there were
programs in place where you they will
build affordable housing in San
Francisco those will cut off and so we
find them on the outskirts of the
political dynamics in San Francisco you
know there's another key part of the
story is Jimmy fails friendship with
Montgomery his best friend and it's
interesting because you don't really see
often the dynamic between two black men
that is so tender
and so loving and so kind but it's not a
romantic relationship talk about why
that was important to you I very rarely
see something like that on the screen
and it was so beautifully done well
you know growing up in in the inner city
is always you know toxic masculinity is
always a thing so you want to want to be
able to explore that and I think that's
important for for younger black men to
see to like you don't have to always be
tough it is black men in a different
light yeah tenderness there were tears
Jimmy there was real emotion between
these two characters yes when you set
out when you started writing this and
the idea you had a Kickstarter campaign
even going to do this movie
I always think sometimes the reality
versus the expectation can be different
what is the reality light compared to
maybe what that expectation was so real
I mean you know you never thought I'd be
on CBS in the morning working the Danny
Glover did whether it's times you have
to say mr. Glover you need to do that
over we need to pull out any Lethal
Weapon lines every once awhile start
quoting on Julian and Danny for you
working with this crew because I know
how much the city of San Francisco means
to you yeah why you wanted to be a part
of this yeah it does I mean and and
because these are two young men yeah oh
I do love the city yeah and that's what
makes it is they love the city and
everything else and it's it's this
generation that are gonna be the ones
who gonna battle and be in the city and
five to the city so we have to fight for
the city the last black man in San
Francisco yeah Bravo well done well done
Jimmy field Danny Glover always good to
see you thank you all right they're
thinking the last black man in San
Francisco is in theaters right now